we may or may not have been lying this
whole time and not actually been live
hello hello everyone hello hello
Lord what a morning what a morning hello
we are here again we are in queue I
realize I did not hit go life but we
have indeed been live for at least 5
minutes we did start up a little late
because we're having technical
difficulties yes sure let's just
reimagine the intro again real quick
boom will be live soon and now intro
what's up everybody how's it going again
it's Tuesday but it's kind of mine it's
a blue so it's definitely definitely
blues day yeah I'm Persia this is David
how you guys Erik take aim to save the
day when we have extreme issues but
unfortunately there's nothing he'll be
able to do about these Q times though
basically what was happening earlier
just now we were we were in the game and
we were going through the kind of like
the beginning exposition right since we
had streamed it right right we had
streamed this game the Alpha stress test
for two separate days myself and Richie
were just you know all over it were
mobbing through the game as fast as we
can and for those of you who were with
us you know we thought it was just gonna
be a repeat you didn't really need to
see all that kind of like entry-level
game stuff it's a lot more fun to kind
of get into the thick of things when you
have more attempt times to kind of
battle and you know you've got more
things that were evolved and all that
stuff but unfortunately within the first
battle the first like trainer the
youngster Joey if you will of Pokemon in
comparison we got stuck pretty much all
of our you know moves just weren't
working I was spamming and it just and
we tried a bunch of different things
tried to change some in-game settings
really you know try to use items or
evade the battle literally could not get
past it we'd try to attack and it was
just stuck it was frozen so we left and
the queue jumped yeah it did we though
it did yeah the queue was initially when
I first booted the GameCubes only
at about 4k 5k and it goes down pretty
fast I know it's a daunting number but
like every three to five minutes or so
it goes down by several hundred to a
couple thousand I think it's because
people just get frustrated and they
leave right and you know it's it's good
to be patient patience is a virtue they
give you the disclaimer right in the
beginning this is not a finished game
right it's totally early access they're
just trying to test it out how the
server's can handle an influx of way
more people someone mentioned it in the
chat earlier small studio pushing out an
ambitious game it's very true it's worth
noting too so for those of you in chat
who haven't seen any gameplay of the
game which we do have up already on our
GameSpot gameplay channel and for those
of you who might not be familiar with it
if you have any questions I am more than
happy to just dive anyway because I've
had like five or six hours with the game
already so and we also have at some
point we might even bring up show you
guys a bit of like their version of the
Pokedex
it's like their little Tim Tam yeah and
their wiki is pretty legit yeah their
wiki it's it's absolutely here I will
link this to you guys just in case
you're curious about some Tim Tam wiki
goodness omission oh okay I want to go
there Twitter I'm sure they're already
addressing the situation 52k followers
it's it's a there you go six minutes ago
while you're on the q screen did you
know that running temp them in there can
be looma - we're still working on
allowing more users in the game and
they're oh they actually restarted the
server maybe that's why you couldn't get
that that's interesting that would make
sense that's why it looks like we still
have some lag problems previous hotfix
worked good but a new issue appeared see
that is the grueling process of coding
right yeah this is one thing and in that
fix it broke something else sure it's a
never-ending cycle so you got some
questions I'm more
Wow we jumped down in the queue by the
way yeah so Allah so realistically is
this Pokemon for PC or a long long way
to go
I think it's Pokemon parallel I don't
think it's hard not to compare the two
you know what I mean like we were
looking at the wiki and you were just
looking at the 10 times you're like oh
my god right it looks like they made
them more in detail than what you know
it's to me it's like Pokemon on like a
watercolor phase or something you know
what I mean yeah it's like wind fan art
of Pokemon come out and it's all like
right he's had an extra of all times
right right that's actually a great
description and the other thing though
is that the only thing that for me
personally that compares to Pokemon is
the fact that you have these sort of
these little monsters that you carry
around and you make them battle with
other people and your goal is to be you
know the best there ever was right I
feel bad like that alone you have these
like sort of these like gyms I don't
know what I forgot what there are
they're called dojos in this game you
know and you just compete so in that
case you can compare a lot to it your
items the way you capture things but
there are some mechanically different
things in this game for example the fact
that everything is a 2v2 there is no 1v1
in this game and the other part that
this is a like MMO you know it's it's
massive it's online and there are people
running around everywhere you go yeah
when we were in the server there was
obviously I feel like this like the way
you run around in the world and
everything is like what Pokemon fans
wanted I think something like that there
was a lot of stuff that Pokemon like you
kind of feel like you're lacking in or
you you kind of want just a little more
intense time has been fairly good at
kind of answering that angle
unfortunately on a like performance
standpoint obviously because it's still
in early access it's being made by a
small group of devs I you know it's got
a long ways to go but it's I don't know
it's cool to be honest well times n be
on switch when release when officially
released MCM does have plans to be
across multiple platforms PC Xbox
Playstation and switch I don't remember
if it's coming out to like Android or
something like that you know but at the
moment it is only PC but you can play
with with the control any Tim Tims well
on there with you there's at least 61
161 listening Wiki currently 161 which
is not a bad start
it's not it's only 10 more than Pokemon
when it started Pokemon had 151 the
other thing that's kind of interesting
is I think you can catch your starters
in the wild in tempt em from what I was
reading out in the wiki they start you
off with it in the beginning but
eventually at some point later down the
road you can you can catch them in the
wild and there's also another
interesting thing too with the I don't
know how much more content the early
access offers but for anyone who has
seen or owned the Alpha stress test
there was a lot you had up to four dojos
which is like dude for like a demo like
that's yeah yeah much so are the
microtransactions right out the gate not
that I've seen no I do not see any
microtransactions I wouldn't be
surprised if there are but it's it's too
early to say they're pretty pretty
cool-looking
Thank You hypno Potamus that's a great
name made my brain turn into mush gotta
tame them all yeah keep the puns coming
guys there's nothing more that I love
more than been puns
I think it's all is it only on PC right
now it is only on PC yeah it will when
the official final game comes out which
there is no release date for it yet it
will eventually come out to Xbox
Playstation and switch but for early
access it is PC only on Steam this
definitely feels like a switch game for
sure it looks like it would be a great
switch game doesn't it yeah Luka says
it's good it will be around 2021
potentially that's gonna come to console
so yeah it is always off year is not
that far no it's not dude this year is
already fired for some of the way done
right crazy this month is already almost
over that's pretty crazy Catherine G
blade says hopefully we'll be cross play
hopefully I think I think cosplay is the
future so and hello to you you can't be
this high there Persia and David how's
it going how was y'all's weekend let's
see what their to see if they give us
any Twitter updates past what we already
had we do know the server has has been
restarted yeah they did restart the
server about 20 minutes ago so that's
already implemented a hotfix but that
hotfix broke something else so they got
a hot fix the hot fix and oh man 20k new
tamers Wow 20k in that little tiny
village that's insane so instead of tea
instead of trainers this team as I get
it I get it it's hard not to compare
this yeah alright so one hour ago they
tweeted Tim Tim early access is
available now massively multiplayer
fully fledged story campaign real co-op
RNG free and competitive focused battles
player customization and trading buy on
Steam or humble and within that hour
they have implemented two hotfix as a
server restart do their they're having a
busy morning yeah exactly it's pretty
cool a new pub scene so da Vinci you
asked if you can play the game yes you
can if you wait for a
ah if you wait for this cue yeah I mean
we started off at about like 16 KQ we're
down to 3k now a couple more minutes but
if we get stuck again at that same spot
it's gonna be a bit of a rip but uh can
we uh do you think we can bring that tab
over to the screen to show the chat some
of the various symptoms yes I think we
can do that let's see how to try to work
on something for you guys do this Q's
going down man to think that we were at
around like 17 K and maybe like 10
minutes ago and now the the queues come
down to a little under 3000
oh we're doing they're just doing some
xsplit magic and the preview editor for
you guys again so probably saying I was
just I mean if that was me I oughta just
like MacGyver did and just chucked the
entire window over then that's not and
we all these ads on this wiki page come
on 23:25 oh my God we're going hey
alright
almost that boy Lou what's good fam how
are you guys and bless bless bless bless
all right I think I've got this hot
screen right here I did it oh yeah all
right yeah so we're just taking a look
at their wiki page here obviously
looking very official this is their
species page though right is essentially
they're kind of like a working pokedex
where you can see what sometimes people
have discovered in the wild so far and
the different types and this is this is
interesting the types have obviously a
lot of similarities to pokemon with only
a few types may be having the same like
fire like what else would you call a
fire type flame type yeah but they've
done a really good job of like of kind
of using synonyms for the other ones
like normal is neutral grass is nature
good nooch psychic is a mental it looks
like rocking ground I've just been
combined to say earth
you got wind and it looks like the only
ones that are actually different than
pokemon is crystal in taxing
yeah toxics just poison right yeah
they're kind of cute though the toxic
Pokemon BQ bro yo I see some toxic
tim-tim up in the chat right on that's
what you should call chat if anyone gets
toxic you just call them the toxic time
zones the digital digital look really
cool yeah and I don't know what types
they actually represent but one of the
starters is a crystal type so that's
cool and it looks like they've got the
the Pokemon thing of them kind of
messing around so you have pyro Iraq and
then grandpa grandpa you don't even have
there some you know some stats yeah
they're pretty cute bun bun so adorable
do you have a favorite so far I do well
so I'm a big fan of my starter if the
crystal but also that other crystal type
that you have above the lap at night
Ozzy rock in Zen earth when I saw those
I was like searching everywhere trying
to find one of those I really really
want that yeah it looks like buff - yeah
it's yoked bro you know the scowl not
amused not a Musil rekt farewell oh nice
even have a little yeah so the thing
with the leveling in this game that's a
lot different than Pokemon is temp Sims
won't evolve at a certain level they'll
evolve like oh wait nevermind what I
thought it actually had where you can
find where you have to you have to train
your Tenten for a certain amount of
levels before it evolves rather than
like oh every Center at the evolve is at
level 30 or whatever
more of like if you cash as an rent at
level 30 or level five as long as you
level it up X amount of levels then it
will eventually evolve so that's kind of
a different take on the evolutions that
they take what is that my shoe
I am god toxic and mainly that sounds
about right
town calls and are I already forgot the
name of the the town Brian Mitchell yes
they already have a wiki absolutely the
dark we're scouring their wiki and their
Twitter page right now trying to get a
glimpse of yeah what's going on what how
did our cue go up to ten thousand I
thought we were at six we were three
thousand or something like that dude we
were at two thousand we were at two
thousand and the queue jumped up so yeah
I am Chuck for real oh you come as a
cute one I like that one too I actually
in the alpha test I captured that one
alright captured a machine and then I
evolved it a little like a dragon eel
looks like toothless almost yeah man
these Q times are no joke we were pretty
close we were literally in the game we
were literally in the game twice yeah
and then they reset the GD server and
now we are back to square one man hey
but this is what we do this is what we
do for you guys you know we braved the
queue times so you don't have to we
stock the Twitter page so you don't have
too few times got mashach you are
absolutely right chips oi
yes geez no these names are great they
are pretty good and it's worth I mean
it's worth plugging again for those of
you who have just joined we have
gameplay up already of tempt em on our
you go to youtube.com slash games while
gameplay you will find I think at least
like 17 or 20 minutes of gameplay of
just running around with crystal and I
sounded familiar Thai foods like tofu
yeah probably
it's hi doggies supposed to be hi Daddy
oh hey doggies never mind never mind
hi Dodie sounds cuter yeah it does it
does gosh I show him so long I forgot
his name he's the neighbor mr. wholesome
no Alicia says same way for a drive
watching history him on her ps4 he's
waiting in a queue as well yeah that's
you know Hughes got us on the ship
that's Chuck do they have an Eevee
equivalent as David no I don't know
I've not seen an Eevee equivalent yet
because I don't think we fully know what
all devolution czar just yet so that
would that would make sense and Derek
they do have cries yes every time you
throw out a tempt em they will make a
some kind of a sound throw them away
like in the trash like that yeah I work
right after the temptones
Ned Flanders there you go thank you
Thank You Chad adoro Boros that is
amazing Tora Bora Bora yeah
that's what it's a mix of adorable
[Music]
adorable he's cute he is Doris
whew Tim Tim are as deceptive as a door
burrows an unusual mix of cute intent oh
my goodness I love it
Derick so how does the capture aspect
work so basically you have these 10
cards it's kind of like a digital holder
you basically toss them like you would
have poked a ball but instead of an
actual ball like kind of capturing a
Pokemon you instead have these digital
cards that sort of kind of like turn
every times them into this data that it
then kind of like in captures into this
card and it just sort of flashes a few
times before it eventually either breaks
or contains the temp time forget and
then you can put it in your squat so
it's very similar to Pokemon although I
haven't seen any like you know great
temp cards or ultra temp cards or
anything like that they all seem to be
pretty plain and straightforward yeah I
think adoro Boros and mashek are my
favorite ones
[Music]
although the Hocus and pocus combination
it's pretty godly focus and it's pretty
good got a little lying in there yeah
reiber
rays and rakin the black coats what
you're saying is it's digimon then a lot
of people have also compared to the
digimon yeah his LV his all feet oh my
god little claws too good do they need
to be low health to catch
and also can you catch them after they
fainted you cannot catch them after they
fainted but they having them be low
health will help you out for sure it
makes it easier and you I think you can
catch him because everything's a 2v2 in
this game
you don't have to make one of the ten
times faint in order to catch the other
alright what else they got on this wiki
here a combat okay it's animated huh oh
that's a competitive bout all I haven't
seen that yet we've only done the
regular TV tease that you get throughout
the training and the dojos says it's a
gift but I see no such movement it's all
good competitive scene is based on TV
two battles with a pic in band system
ooh that's interesting that sounds fun
each player can have up to eight tim-tim
in their competitive squad there are
three slots for that and we'll take
turns deciding which tim-tim they choose
for themselves and which tim-tim they
want to ban from the opponent and so
they end up with five tim-tim that will
be used to battle ain't it US team
definitely feels a bit competitive
obviously yeah it's like I really
couldn't think of a better word but well
named
well names breeding yeah I got an egg
system I'm shocked right now look at
that so cute little toes I don't have a
foot fetish I swear but adorable that's
cool they like reflect the type they
have that's really cool I like that a
lot more I would love a set like IRL
of those like a collective collect that
would be cool right yeah yeah have like
collector packs with a certain type of a
vague that'd be really dope Avalon don't
jinx it my man
don't get us mashach he's saying it'll
probably go back up to 10 no no we're at
4,600 its progress it's progress
although we got down to two Kao 3797 65
hello Home Slice I wonder I wonder how
how well twitch is faring like if Tom
Sam usually one of game drops it climb
they show you what the baby will look
like oh my god I'm looking at the
breeding page around the wiki so are
these the parents and this is what your
baby will look like that's adorable that
is great
Derrick O'Neal's asking as if I work for
Pokemon he's like the egg designs match
the temp times
why hasn't Pokemon done this game spot
dude you yes that's this is like when
Viva Pinata was out and I wanted to like
mix breeds but you couldn't this is like
that that's adorable dams OSE techniques
alright guys you guys are gonna learn
some things about breeding from this
game alright they're gonna teach you
about some techniques single values
that's always important when it comes to
breeding you guess I'm trying I think
because it's like in comparison to
pokemons like a V and IV system it looks
like theirs has a kind of like a
different reworked system with single
values the treats are not inherited and
instead will be selected randomly upon
hatching right
what is luma God I wish I knew
around the wiki we must know a way I
think luma is like their version of
shinies that's what it is
so alternative color variants to Noir
Yeah right right right
we um some of the chats asking how the
queue is going it's we're at 24 16 right
now we're making some good progress
almost there don't worry guys we're not
just sitting here looking at wiki
because that's what we want to do right
we want to play as much as you guys want
to watch this play yeah yo Bob Jones
what uh
bookbag has going hey Bob Jones welcome
back to another ten time stream although
this one's got a bit of a rockier start
and the ones you've joined because we
got like 20,000 more people trying to
play this game at the same time yeah you
know it's the new hotness no one wants
to miss out they don't want to be
mashach they don't want to be Michelle
oh we got some anthem roasting in the
chat my god yeah you guys got to leave
anthem alone man that games that cameras
fizzled alright let him be it is what it
is
what's the name of the temp Sam that's
just running on this loading screen for
the last leg baby piggy pick would you
believe that this if chat had a guess
what type pick a peck oh yeah curious
what they would guess is actually pretty
I think on point just because you know
what something like ooh when pigs fly
[Music]
okay that's a good clue he doing it
[Laughter]
piggy Pig it's a small fluffy Pig like
Tim Tim all his snot is a heart that's
cute you can't you guys can't really see
it from profile view you see the outline
of it a little bit if you know it's all
right reading about a little piggy pick
here
hey chats dude chats no they're uh they
know their temp times eh
most of them guess that it was a it's a
wind type yeah yeah see I was like you
know that's seeing is as old as time and
that's usually you know people go for
that so you guys are smarter than me
flying pig thing yeah
epic Flying Pig if it goes any higher
than this don't jinx it someone knock on
wood I know is this way fake fake wood
dude we got this a thousand 75 I'm Jed
asks what starter do you want to choose
my man I already chose my starter I am
[Applause]
alright a quick up in there yo do it if
you just wait in like the the menu too
long I like you I don't even play
right we get no and chillin I'm gonna I
don't know if I should run into that
battle right away or if I should stuck
at the starting battle twice yeah which
is why we ended up in the queue again
right so me what do you say so ya know
that battle is not good news right now
so let's explore the town then so you
guys can see what it's like the DAR it's
worth noting that everyone with over
there you know that's an actual player
yeah these are people OTT of people
starting their journey other people in
that house keyword control so I'm gonna
go back to controller yeah have a nice
day biggie sick so we got some very
friendly people in town this is your
home that's your mom mama I almost
couldn't come home the cute things yeah
mom you have no idea the day that I just
said yeah it's like cute I was like Bert
yeah do you seriously it's like just a
little bit of rain and everyone loses
their mind Andrew said this looks sexy
Loki it's beautiful it really is
beautiful I really like how it looks I
like it you can run around like this and
your will attempt to follow you around
q-dance catches you don't want to talk
to me yo next to you ro why you got a
dislike hey you know anyone want to sit
down you can actually like interact with
the Empire
[Music]
I got this well everyone this is my
starter by the way this is crystal he's
chasing me yeah
crystal first name crystal last name
cleared
yo that portends him over there oh
that's a graduation I should not go
anywhere near that thing
house party day it is can we confirm if
it's 60 frames is this 60 frames I don't
know I mean we can we can't confirm just
go to here
[Music]
the power of the 10 Tim but yeah there
you go is this the moment of truth it is
because last time we battled oh boy it
broke but without all the trainer's love
of God Tatsu okay all right
choose a target okay okay so far so good
let's go all right we couldn't get past
that partner here so this is a good sign
let's go you have no idea how badly my
heart stopped all right let's go man
they're too cute yeah I'm just gonna
absolutely this is early access to you
guys so it's only on PC at the moment
correct but uh yeah it's looking good
looking good
[Music]
at least we have some background music
this time we could have used this music
in the queue all right the door is the
dark it's it's stuck the dark out here
yo yo not like this
Tim Tim yep we need some F's in the chat
yeah please we need some pho mousse in
the chat which is the name of attempt to
my juicer I just looked at the list and
said the first name that started with an
F and it was foam ooh who did the their
Twitter didn't just oh yeah let's check
the Twitter
let's check the Twitter again you set
the server again they said server
restart incoming sick they said we're
adding a new hot fix reducing room sizes
in order to alleviate the problems we're
having while we investigate them server
restart incoming oh my god server
restart incoming oh my God look at that
dude look at the colors the dude found
this shiny and he can't catch it
[Music]
it's so cute - yo the strap my god yeah
faux mousse in the chat y'all boo
Akash has to tell me research they do
bro at least like for three or four
we've had a couple of uh oh my god Home
Slice is it just server issues or do you
think it's something more sinister or is
it all in elaborate hood
yeah yeah for sure yeah
rest in peace of that guy and his shiny
yeah honestly would you just stay on
that screen until it was fixed and hope
that it like worked out oh well I feel
like it would it would be to the didn't
press escape no the only thing I can do
is is a staple mood yep
[Music]
I mean it is you know it is let's see
what this cute times that now yeah let's
let's play the game called cute I'm on
day one of a MMO with over 25,000 people
wanting to play at the same time whoo oh
lordy go with that boom boom yeah that's
fun move oh yeah sure she got some real
I prefer he came out to Tom says he knew
what was up
he's the new he's the new F dude he is
home was the new s anytime you want to
put F in chat just say yeah a full moon
FF o moon fun was fine
I love it Korn props is they tweeted
that loading times for battles are long
and they are fixing yeah that makes
sense we we've had that we've had that
issue one minute ago updates live
updates you guys from the Twitter feed
one minute ago hot dang we detected a
new issue yeah corn pops on it they're
working on the issues to expect a hot
fix soon thank you all for being so oh
yeah this guy Fedora is he back in chat
talking about the luma he's still on
every single he's like you guys got a no
I wasn't lying it was a real shiny legit
though this case right perhaps a team
now I'm stop breaking with mom cell
communication hey absolutely is why you
have early access so you know what to
expect when the full release is out dude
every single freaking destiny dlc update
I go through this so it's not upside
down that black screen a sent us into
the upside down this is our there you go
it's all right we got foam wheel here to
save the day unicorn Narwhal they did
read our mind i gosh it's a narwhal on a
cloud don't spam this on every single
thing in so they get I fully expect him
to be on the on the reddit for Samsung
yeah he's gonna have a vendetta I can
send him if they don't deem is goes hope
that autosave on Dec yeah the game
auto-saves like everything it's kind of
crazy I never have to save it just does
it for me which is kind of a good and a
bad thing you know you can't really save
scum but also I guess MMOs are kind of
you know they're meant that way anyway
it would be really sucky
to rewind back things that you did that
might potentially affect other people
well ding
at least we got to run around a little
bit yeah we did almost had us you know
they had us in the first half not gonna
lie
then they let us have a little halftime
show then they got us in the second half
- whoa hold it hold the phone now we're
stuck here we're back this is foam Lou's
house oh yeah now he was right next to
me shook dude I feel like I'm waiting on
a frickin supreme drop right now are the
the black cats that are dropping
tomorrow 7 a.m. it's like sneakers app
just goes down
Lomu my life man boom ooh my life my
life all right
take four because this game is too fired
type right now these two so much wait
let me look up some fire champs here I
mean some some fire types this games -
oh wait now I need a username to
pronounce
not sure if we can do it after we go
through this but can we maybe just play
some of the gameplay that we have yeah
from the last from the actual like
breakout from the gameplay channel we
can just throw it up show people what it
looks like and just talk over it while
this reconnects phew for the last 30
minutes
well at least our description is
accurate
we are combating these crazy yeah
lordy Lordy
alright check this out y'all will at
least put some yeah boom re hold looks
like they underestimated the amount of
people yeah re re hold up we got some
here here enjoy this gameplay yeah so
this is gameplay from the gameplay
channel from our last break out during
the alpha and it
got the same the same footage that you
would probably go through during this
early access test you know just some
shameless plug it's a good way for you
guys to kind of see what the yeah well
the game actually looks like you know
just you guys should be able to hear
this audio so this was footage from when
we had the beta the alpha it was a
stress us although we got early access
codes for that and it was only it only
lasted about three days and it was kind
of like see how far you can get in those
three days and it was really expensive
like I said earlier there was up to four
dojos and just getting to the first dojo
it took like almost one to two hours of
gameplay and that's actually like
mopping through kind of like trying to
speedrun it skipping all of the optional
side-quests and there's a lot there oh
there's no audience dang well I actually
don't know how to fix that so enjoy this
silent gameplay I feel like there's a
way to do it maybe it's this one yeah
rip erroneous audio is real low everyone
asked will you lose everything after the
early access is done that's a good
question because you we did lose all our
progress from the Alpha and there were
transparent about that in the beginning
so if they mention it here then probably
I would say that you'd probably have to
reset whenever they do release a full a
full release I got a funny story from
you know that movie
quiet please oh yeah I had accidentally
watched that movie on mute and I didn't
know it and I thought it was a part of
the beginning of the movie that the
whole thing was silent and I was like oh
this makes sense a quiet place no audio
all right you know this is kind of
intense that that's a good story dude
I'm shocked you haven't told me that
yeah and like half of its in subtitles
also I really didn't know I only
realised later because I went on YouTube
my YouTube was muted and I was like
no wonder that's so funny
we got an ad Oh get out of your grammar
yeah dear ed we're trying to watch our
silent movie yeah come on dare goes the
reddit forum for temp times already
packed well over 3k oh my god chats
loving your yeah it wasn't my proudest
moment I had actually what was more
hilarious was that I went on to YouTube
to watch like youtubers review the movie
that was like oh this is really
interesting that they kept it all silent
when I see people on YouTube have to say
and I went and watched its youtuber i
watch shudos movie reviews and the
beginning started it was all silent and
I thought they were doing a bit like
they were making fun in the movie so
they started that way and then after
like you know five minutes of it I was
like wait this is uh this isn't right
that is really really funny I mean tell
me stuff I would go back and watch it
with audio I just never did you know
it's it's one of those things - were
like the actual I mean obviously the
quiet places because they don't speak
right like there is there is sound and
that's what makes it so chilling you
know everyone sending me their phone
moves for me watching quiet this is not
a finished game early in development
version of the game whose main
objectives to help make time time better
in the long run I'm sure they've learned
a lot today
indeed versions eliminated content
features and ballads just a lot of
content if we can just get to it and you
expect to find some budge and you're
expected to find some I hope maybe if I
just like the guy with the luma just
like can you hotfix the Loom I found
into my store
can you I wonder if I should turn off
anything that's automatic and just like
oh they've detected another issue a
hotfix for the hotfix coming soon
restarting the server but we've detected
an issue in the hotfix context for the
hotfix coming soon and that's where
Fedora said can you have fix Illume I
found into my squad bro the luma guy if
you look at this it's kind of hard to
see Twitter oh you can't see it in the
way it's cropped right here but can see
right there look
yeah you Besta by some windows you
cannot get away with nothing on Twitter
chat says Clovis
says I'm so confused I thought it was
officially releasing today oh good it is
a official early access release yes
official early access release hmm so you
know when they're like I restart we
restarted the server
you know I'm thinking like when I
restart my router it only takes like a
couple of minutes but I wonder how long
in total does it take to fully restart a
game server that's a good question
I mean clearly there I mean there's no
way they're just sitting there right
like they're probably hustling you know
their tails off and running around
trying to find a way to solve this
because a lot of people want to play
this game thank you a lot of people want
to play working there 10 Tim's off I
feel like you get you're at your most
creative
adversity is so funny - Twitter's a
toxic temp temp yes indeed that's so
funny
but not the adorable whirls kind adoro
burrows I love that name fight a pet I'd
name it adorable
I wouldn't mind my shucks shucks right
my chick is is fighter type for sure
even though he's not are these supposed
to be my shucks mitts like you're gonna
box you he's ready to square up he's
happy about it to catch these hands
that's great
barn Qi Davis goes is there an hour cap
I don't think so
no there shouldn't be any type of cap
they're just having some server issues
and they're doing their best to fix it
all up and solve them yeah everybody
wants to play
I thought you named it foe mu you right
right that's a good point yeah like that
you ready rate yeah that's some shade
first name foam ooh middle name we
should go fo MU versus my shirt who you
think take it up a level here well so
fun was gonna have the foam is gonna be
strong
in the beginning I feel like bucks gonna
take it the full nine rounds where my
[ __ ] got stamina I'm looking at all
their shiny versions which is pretty
cool
other Lumas yeah like our boy Fedora
wants his uh yeah
they are cool I think um when I think of
like Pokemon Chinese some of them are
really really dope there's also other
Chinese where just doesn't do much for
me this reminds me of
sylveon which is my favorite oh yeah
pokey man's poke man's like my grandpa
used to say to make fun of me whenever
we were collecting those little cards
then poke man's for poke man's poke
man's so cute that is cute
that's cooler than the pig epic I feel
like Pig epic is that his name mm-hmm
Pigpen I was calling piggy pig piggy
Peck I lost my original page oh I see
Brendan asked what are the shiny rates
in this game it's one out of six
thousand so reasonably easier to get
then then like a Pokemon shiny sometimes
I think the rate for Pokemon Chinese
yo-yo hold up this I'm looking at
Plataea pets evolution why does he just
get more and more
he just gets more and more fed up with
your BS it's over time nice and innocent
right this is like first day you know
our first day of school start getting
pretty upset incredible that was great
such a mood
all right come on Tim Tim sound time
yeah like 20 minutes my guy at least we
got to run around for Oliver two minutes
we just had to go looking for trouble
didn't kidding Jessica do ddotty all
over the town without fighting
Markus is everybody's having the same
problems playing this game yeah hence
the nature I mean that they're not even
giving us a cue time anymore they're
just straight up saying like yeah this
stuff's down
let's people I feed you can only imagine
what their office is looking like hurry
now people are running around running
it's a spongebob when yeah in their
brain or whatever trying to find his
name like the whole office is on fire
maybe platter pet was frustrated with
the key wait sighs this way he slowly
got more angry oh boy oh yeah she Kippur
I spent 40 minutes to find your DBZ
Kakarot 90-minute video everything set
the livestream thanks for spending that
much time to find our video that was a
fun stream I had a lot of fun on that
I'm having way more fun this one was
hate which one oh yeah yeah which one
[Music]
yeah kids on the devs are restarting the
server with the hot chicks in fact
they're restarting the server with the
hotfix for the HOF --ax yes
so yeah that's what it does have updates
there they're doing their best
[Music]
well well well you guys not sure how
much more of this wiki page I could look
at customization let's see we're talking
about the characters yeah tell us about
oh that's pretty cool
tell us about that some character
customization options that's got double
gin in there yeah it's so I haven't seen
that level of customization yet so at
the beginning customization that you
don't have it's kind of like things you
can do with your hair things you can
change color so you get that currency
just by I think that's the currency yet
just for playing the game yo they got
ninja is there in here oh my god he's
everywhere they do the skinning
fortnight not onlys got a mock Jensen
yeah in Timm Timm lordy Lordy so the
customization is pretty cool in terms of
like the colors you have like a very
wide range of colors you can do versus
just seeing street fighter ii it's got
those fighting games all over that's
awesome their arm seems like there's
some pretty cool things though like I
didn't know you could attach wings I
would be very into finding some double
chin wings so disappointing there's no
cat fun semsem pre-alpha launch I'm just
learning all kinds of things today about
the bow tomb to do that is insane
they've reached yes that is incredible
every backer will have a taco hat that's
don't attack back I'm getting hungry I
could go for a dent on some coffee I
would love that
oh gosh next seeking of marshmallow will
appear incessant yeah they'll have a
live concert oh yeah that'd be great
I like his sad happy sounding songs sad
happy sad songs but they sound happy
that's the 20 25 supposed to be Pooky
Pooky Pooky Pooky
wow I'm pretty sure it's probably Pookie
oh we got taco emojis I did Chad shoots
we got we got foam oma shook and now
tacos boom ooh foam ooh yeah FOMO fear
of missing out FOMO is the friendly eye
not good at anagrams sappy happy and I
was like I had to stop and think what
does I know for a moment I wasn't sure
it's looking like a wash right now I'm
not gonna lie
yeah if I cannot get into the game later
today though I'll I'll do a breakout
okay I'll get a bunch of gameplay and
I'll throw it up on youtube.com slash
GameSpot for you guys you guys can
definitely check it out and see ya see
what it looks like so that could be fun
it is a it is a fun game
I find myself falling into a low when I
play it just like bobbing through and
getting it to that sort of loop like
airborne archipelago is the location
where Tim Tim is set it is where humans
coexist peacefully with creatures called
Tim Tim very nice I'm learning you're
gonna be the dark side yeah I will be
the wiki the walking wiki as the mantras
of the Miyako sages say reality is but
one facet of the universe hmm that's
true
I suppose Oh Derek says it appears that
being on ahirat FM is the game's
legendary that's fun you know these
names dill amnesia
what Denis Denis Denis all right seppuku
Seekonk ooh keep on cou Kashiwa to kuma
tuck ma these names got me mashek do
these names begin all this much muck I
love that they don't even have like how
to pronounce the words like yeah tuck ma
the end of all things what a vast
desolation of ashes oh yeah I was gonna
say this must be where the toxic Tim's
from their homeland
yo this is great every time I see
someone toxic I'd be like go back to
tuck my right tire to you before I get
you all muck at this point it is we're
gonna have the Tim Tim or
dictionary coming soon they showed a
tim-tim enemy that's crazy
that's I'd watch it now that I'm
learning about you know the universe and
how we got it Tuchman there's gonna be
the ones that are like you know they're
the bad guys are the story oh you saw
the end of all things
that's that's where mostly of the
powerful tip times are dude if you had a
guess which ones talking well it's gotta
be yeah exactly
you had to guess which one was suck well
either that or maybe even the one above
it cuz they said it was like desolate
like yeah that's crazy I still think
this slide right here what's this place
this place looks beautiful
I think that's the the opening section
yeah yeah I was I was going through the
first dojo and on my way there you gotta
like climb up these like really really
really tall hills that kind of wanted to
these sort of mountain ranges and it was
cool yeah Denise it's gotta be air right
that's the beginning part it's a
Mediterranean paradise glittering seas
water and wind time time abound yep
that's the one looks like they might be
in order then explore the ruins of
ancient fort where is that though
ancient fort maybe this one I think
that'd be a good one and it looks like
it looks like took my house through the
dark one because I think has ropes and
stuff
sun-drenched savanna that's gonna be the
one on the top that we thought might be
the other temp time or the other
Tuchman no no no top left top left I
feel like that's gotta be it
a sun-drenched savanna right that was
like open fields and stuff that's a good
point I always just think of like the
Lion King
remote hills among rice paddles I don't
know you guys man you see what the
Twitter says if they that hot fix to the
hot babes hot fix that extra hot that
spicy fix how's it going no new updates
last update was the spicy fix 25 minutes
ago when they're restarting the server
yeah we okay
server is under maintenance at this time
please try reconnecting again well guys
we legit sat here and talked to guys for
almost 90 minutes straight no gameplay
hope you guys still love us very much
where's our award I know I should
nominate us we for real just kind of
took you guys down this encyclopedia
you know pathway of tempt M everyone is
more knowledgeable of symptom now then
said the anime trailer is on the steam
page oh you should pull that up go out
on a high note see where the anime is I
think this is cool to you about it being
a smaller studio is that they can do
stuff like hey fans pick a name for this
Tintin and all that good stuff
it's got some anime music that's no I
need help yeah there we go
froze so it's an animation somebody in
my heroes or is this just the game
trailer cute this this has to be Anna
hey I didn't realize there was actual
cards involved in this this is like this
is nicer than the new art design from
put one of those hey watch this
[Music]
you know I hope that's what Chris Wilson
[Music]
took the power or was it because I said
it wrong
I have no idea at with other players in
the air ball dude I know you got caught
think what this game is that like it's
really cool I just I liked when I was
playing through it it did get a little
seen but it's still it's so really worth
giving credit
like how ambitious this project is
battles intent mr2 there was some sort
of legit card play going on I thought it
was just like you know they're your pets
and they run around like a true mix of
like yugioh and Pokemon that encourages
strategic play that one's pretty I
really want that it actually looks like
a Pokemon legendary you can greet em
time to transfer techniques and traits
creating unique combinations that can't
be found in the wild master the breeding
system cannot be tam-tam is the next
evolution of creature collecting games
yes each a creature collecting games
want to know more sign up for future
beta stress tests online and join our
official Tim Tim to score channel for
news and feedback wish list it's like a
joint our very welcoming communities
awesome and well well it's really nice
of Tim time to to have some super hype
it just kind of sucks that nothing seems
to too low just yet but what can he do
yeah I mean I'd be if we got into the
game right now that would just be so sad
it would be I'm not gonna lie though
I've been steadily watching an increase
in their follower account as we've been
sitting here by like the thousands oh
yeah
they had like fifty one thousand earlier
and there
sighs all right you guys that that's
gonna wrap it up thanks for hanging out
with us and chillin with us for a whole
90 minutes without any gameplay I mean
yeah like well we had we had two minutes
you had like 27 seconds we have some
foam cues yes full-moon the foam ooh
Israel thank you guys so much for tuning
in so sorry we actually couldn't get
into the game and do more but hey early
access small studio with a big project
what can you do what can you do
hopefully we'll be able to get into the
game at some point and play again but
until next time we'll see you guys later
join us here every weekday at 11 a.m.
right here on the you tube on the
GameSpot YouTube channel yeah Lomu don't
say mashup yo take it easy
yes don't be my shirt goodbye
you